We blame meteorologists for a lot.
They ruin camping trips, golf trips, days
at the beach.
Why are they always wrong?!
I’m going to say something controversial
here.
Weather forecasting isn’t bad.
It’s actually really accurate.
Bare with me.
To get a prediction on the weather, someone
has to measure humidity, wind speed, rain,
sun, clouds, dew point, and a hundred other
things all over the world.
It’s crazy to think about the amount of
data we need just to say if it’s going to
rain on Thursday.
To paraphrase a famous astrophysicist -- “the
weather is under no obligation to make sense
to you.”
And yet, we keep trying.
For most of the 20th century, weather forecasting
was mediocre because we didn’t have two
things, satellites and supercomputers.
Once we got those, we really knocked it out
of the sunny ballpark.
In 1972, we could predict temperatures in
a range of plus or minus 6 degrees (~3C).
Like it’s going to be “in the 60s (15-20C)”
Now it’s 2 to 3 degrees (~1C).
There’s a big difference between the high
60s and low 60s.
And, we get rain right about 82-percent of
the time.
That’s fantastic, considering we didn’t
even know what a cold or warm front was 100
years ago.
Like I said though, satellites and supercomputers.
Satellites made weather forecasting amazing.
The first sat to take pictures of clouds over
the US was TIROS-1 in April of 1960.
In the first week it spotted a typhoon.
That was huge.
Tropical storms, hurricanes, typhoons -- they
were difficult to detect before satellites.
We’ve launched dozens of weather sats in
the last 57 years, with the newest making
the originals look like the Stone Age.
Now we can see cloud patterns, spot tropical
storms as they form, see heat maps, and even
see differences between “clouds, water vapor,
smoke, ice and volcanic ash.”
It’s insane.
But as we got more data, it started to just…
be too much for our puny human brains to fathom.
Around the turn of the last century numerical
weather monitoring was first attempted.
It applied physics of the atmosphere to weather.
Meteorologists divided the world into a grid
of small imaginary boxes, and calculated the
weather in each box and how it would affect
the boxes around it.
. And it turns out, this is kinda impossible
without a computer!
It took a 1920s mathematician three months
to predict 24 hours of weather.
Supercomputers can run many millions of these
grid calculations per second.
Each time they use real weather data and create
a simulation of what could happen.
Humans could not do this… not even close.
Daily, NOAA’s supercomputer pumps through
data equal to more than twice the entire printed
collection of the Library of Congress.
Even still, weather models (or simulations)
aren’t perfect.
There are lots of them used by different organizations
all over the world, and they’re always tweaking
‘em based on new research…And yet, the
supercomputer can only get so far.
Humans have to be part of the equation.
The National Weather Service says humans improve
rain forecasting by 25-percent, because let’s
be clear, computers only know what we tell
them.
They can’t infer or guess; they just calculate.
And it’s not like before sats and supercomputers
we knew nothing like Jon Snow.
Before space travel, we used (and still use)
radar, balloons, and weather stations spread
across the country and the ocean.
And before electronics, people could look
at the sky or read almanacs!
Seriously!
Red sky in the morning sailors warning, has
to do with atmospheric thickness, red light
scatters the least -- so it can make it through
the thicker air of a possible stormfront.
Stars below a 40 degree angle twinkle normally,
but stars overhead don’t.
When the higher-up stars start to twinkle…
rains a-comin’!
Not to mention people kept records of weather
on days of the year -- knowing the history
helps us predict the future, but it’s not
very precise.
Almanacs are bad weather predictors.
And snow in April doesn’t mean global warming
is a hoax.
Weather is big and complicated and global.
We’re still figuring it out.
In the end, stop raining on your local meteorologists
parade.
Climate and weather are different things,
btw.
I’m not even going to touch that today,
But if global warming is real, then is NASA
lying?
Because Antarctic ice is growing!
Find out more about it in this video.
Do you love your local meteorologist?
Tell me your thoughts in the comments, and
please take a second and subscribe to the
channel!
Thanks for watching, fam!